[Music]
He's telling him to grab the phone of
Allah God and shake it and just shake it
>> the way you know how to shake it.
>> Yes. and shake it like they're basically
in a nutshell saying so that the the the
the temple and the things can come
faster.
>> Asalam allaykum. I really want to thank
forever for partnering with Abdullah in
this absolutely amazing very very
important project of providing
prosthetic limbs to those thousands
who've lost their limbs in Gaza. They
are telling us that this is the best
gift you could have given us. restoring
the mobility is like restoring their
lives. That's what they're saying. So,
subhan Allah, people have lost both
limbs, people have lost hands and legs,
some above the knee, some below the
knee. Mashallah, this is just one
example
Ahmed. Mashallah, he's one of the so
many whom we've been able to assist with
your partnership. So may Allah reward
you and grant you goodness and may Allah
almighty continue to use all of us to do
this good work
[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well inshallah. Uh we
bring you another video uh of a another
funeral of an IDF genocidal soldier uh
being killed uh in Gaza. So this is the
funeral and I found it quite bizarre and
shocking. Um I mean no I wouldn't say
shocking. I mean I haven't gone past the
stage of shocking. Anything is expected
sadly. And if anyone was to say what
this woman her his wife is saying,
they'll be classed as an anti-semitic
straight out. Their whole life would be
ruined. Korea's over. But she's fine.
She can full. And it's also anti-mitism
to say against Arabs, by the way.
>> Exactly. So, we're going to go to the
video. Before we go to the video, guys,
do not forget to download our Salah Pro
app. It is out in thanks to your
donations. Alhamdulillah. We spent 20
plus thousands on the app. It's got a
free kibla finder. Ads free salah
reminders, salah times, tells you the
best time to pray. It's for free. You
can book a salah instructor, order a
guided prayer mat, watch salah videos,
find your local salah hub, and we've got
amazing new page coming favors page
where there's videos telling you reasons
to pray. You can download the app now on
Android and iOS Salah Pro. Let's get
straight into the video, shall
>> and donate at the same time.
>> And yep, if you want to donate, please
do. So, here is the widow of uh Abraham.
This guy who uh actually like a coward,
he actually fell from the run was run
from the bula. Uh there was some footage
that was released.
>> He was a great man and did great things.
She Okay. So someone that says he's a
great man and does great things. You
expect them to do things that serve
humanity.
>> Save life inventing. Inventing
inventions some some cure for cancer
things like that. Things to serve
humanity.
>> Let's see what he was doing.
forchech.
[Music]
Okay. So, first thing she's talking
about how he would demolish houses.
>> Yeah.
>> Of innocent Palestinians.
>> And this is what she calls a great
mission.
>> That they they used to leave her. I
mean, we had soldiers
demolition for birthdays, for
>> you think gender reveals for the babies.
>> For the babies, for all kind, for all
kind. They were demolition. and and
actually filming it and uploading it on
the internet for the whole world to see.
>> And so this is this is and this is what
is the great mission. What a wonderful
man he was. Yes. May Allah deal with him
in this life and the hereafter. And you
and you are crying.
>> You know what you should be crying for?
You should be crying for you should be
crying for yourself that you have this
belief system.
>> But but did you know one thing? Look at
the difference.
>> Subhan Allah. A doctor lost her husband.
None of her children
the im she was standing with
>> the confidence she had. Why? She knows
that Allah subhana wa ta'ala is the
giver and the taker Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala who grants life
>> and and and they were innocent. If
there's anyone that should cry,
>> she should cry.
>> She is she is crying over a genocidal
maniac who was a coward who fell off the
bulldozer. Bulldozer running away. Yes.
Um at least fight like a man. you get if
you're fighting Hamas fight you know
whatever it is and coming killing
innocent people demolishing their houses
and she is here crying you should cry
for what you stand for
[Music]
she goes if you catch her she's like you
know basically saying that you know they
sort beautiful man. Her husband,
>> your husband is there occupying
>> your husband is there to killing
innocent people
>> and you are surprised that
>> demolishing the rooms
>> their houses and then she goes that
place basically this evil what they
done.
>> What did you want them to do? Throw
flowers.
>> Not only that, she goes that place is a
place of evil. There should be children
rejoicing. I think she's talking about
children. You know what she goes?
>> No, she's talking about
>> for holy Jewish families who who live
who are excit
>> You can't make this stuff up. Foreign
it will be settlers. The settlers
mentality they have go. the settlers
mentality they have got. So this war is
not a war to to to to retrieve the uh
the kidnapped.
>> None of that.
>> It's a war actually
>> to ethnically clean.
>> Yes. She goes that filthy that filthy
land
>> filthy trap. That filthy strap
>> that filthy strip.
>> The only one that's filthy is you when
your ideology you disgusting. What kind
of a person are you? I'm I cannot make
this stuff up. But let's carry on. Now
this is his friends. Let's see how
they're mourning his death.
If Arabs continue to live, we are
failed. Imagine if I came and said if
Jewish Jews carry on living, we are
failed. Prophet, let me tell you
something, I will be arrested, sent to
prison. Sheh, I'm telling you, if I was
to say if Jews carry on living, we
haven't finished our mission yet.
>> Yeah.
>> Look at so casually.
>> Okay. So casually.
>> Now look at that. You're saying that the
problem is with the uh Hamas.
>> Yeah.
>> So why why the killing of the innocent
people then? Why you want to wipe out
the other generation?
>> If it's Hamas, then why attacking West
Bank?
>> Why attacking the West Bank? many
things. So many things, you know,
>> if your problem is Hamas, fix it with
Hamas.
>> Yeah. And talk about Abraham, Abraham
was a coward. He died as a coward. This
one is a special scum. This This here is
now a special kind of scum. Yeah. He's a
special one. Look at this. Look at this
one now. Look what he has to say. Watch
this. Listen to this. This one is a
passionate dirt bag. I hope you guys
enjoy the video, guys. But before that,
please download the Salah Pro app,
brothers and sisters. We are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free kiba finder. No ads, free
salah reminders, encourages to pray,
tells you salah time. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. Videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more
brother sisters. We are not an app that
shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now inshallah
and enjoy guys. Let's go back to the
video.
So you see it's not even Hamas. They're
not talking about Hamas. If you think
about they
>> Palestinian
>> they say you know what is very
interesting like they're specifically
saying
>> Arabs Palestinians
>> when that singer um I forgot his name.
Bob Villain who said death and IDF.
Yeah.
>> Subhan Allah. He's specifically saying
these soldiers these guys
>> organization is talking about
organization.
>> Exactly. and he was a a military and he
was deemed an anti-semite. These guys,
they get away with they're talking about
innocent people, but they get away with
it.
All
[Music]
right, here it gets really interesting,
guys. This is where it gets real
interesting. So, he is now talking about
Abraham. Abraham is in a hellfire, by
the way. Yeah, for you guys to know,
he's in a hellfire. May Allah subh burn
him more. Yes, he's a genocidal maniac
who's in the hellfire inshallah. Um,
look what he has to say now. He's
telling Abraham, he's on the other side,
not knowing he's burning. He can't grab
anything. Uh, but anyway, so he's giving
him a command now. What's the command?
Let's see.
[Music]
die in your rage. That's what I'm going
to say in. So he's telling him to grab
the phone of Allah, God, and shake it.
>> Just the way you know how to shake it.
>> Yes. And shake it like they're basically
in a nutshell saying so that the the the
the temple and the things come faster.
>> So that the the males
the the Messiah comes quicker.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> That's why the shade of so much blood
because of these uh
>> these fanatics, these extremists,
>> the shed of blood will kind of push the
coming of the Messiah quicker.
>> That's why they cause corruption on
earth. These reason they do this is
because they believe the more the
corruption, the faster the Messiah
comes. That's the reason why they do. If
you look behind all of these atrocities,
all these, they are behind it. And the
whole world is waking up to this. They
are behind all of this stuff.
>> Alhamdulillah. People in Europe are
waking up. People in America are waking
up. People in China, in Japan, in Korea,
in
>> everywhere.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, you know what? uh he didn't he
did a disfavor to uh to the Zionist
plan this Netanyahu
>> and Benir and
>> that they thought that they're doing
something good
>> for the cause
>> but they have killed cause people now
they don't sympathize with them anymore
>> 100% because they plan and Allah plans
you know
>> brothers and sisters that's all we have
to say for today inshallah download the
salah pro app it's absolutely for free
in enjoy it and benefit from inshah and
it can be a means of for our donors.
Till next time
and watch out for our exclusive blog
from China.
>> Yes, inshallah we're going in China in
brother and sisters for the guided
prayer mats and we've got an exclusive
blog coming out soon in brother and
sisters. Keep an eye out for that. Till
next time.